Pokemon games may predate the TV show
but for many of us he was watching the
animated series that really made us want
to catch em all a lot of memorable
moments in the series some of them were
triumphs while others were tribulations
they celebrated 25th anniversary of the
Pokemon series we're taking a look back
at some of these moments and
highlighting five of our favorites in
episode 1 of Pokemon Ash and Pikachu me
and initially don't see eye to eye but
by the time the episode is done they
resolve their differences and work
together to defeat a group of PC
sparrows
there's an important moment because
viewers get to see what pokemon is
really all about friendship
and the bond between trainer and pokémon
ash in the gang come across a chow
manner that's been abandoned by its
trainer a Charmander off the rescue from
their death
the to take a stand against the abusive
trainer and then begin a long story
journey together this is a sad story
about how the loyalty of a pokemon can
be abused but also how friendship can be
a powerful asset caches Caterpie longs
could be a powerful Pokemon and after
overcoming some challenges they evolved
into a Butterfree
together they defeat Pokemon trainers
and even some gym leaders the moral of
this story is if you really believe in
yourself you can achieve anything after
its humble beginnings Ash's Charmander
evolves into an unruly and
uncontrollable Charizard the Toras I
learned some hard lessons when he meets
a poly ref that beats the crap out of it
Ash refused to give up on his fiery
friend and nurses it back to health once
again this reminds Charizard of all the
good times they've spent together and
they get over this rocky patch in their
friendship and become best friends once
again this last one isn't a single
moment but something you can learn from
ashes career he's never actually won a
pokemon league but that's not important
it's still a legendary training well
repay them what this means is that you
don't have to be showered with
championship accolades to be important
you can forge your own legend by making
a difference for the people and pokémon
around you you know ash you raised
Butterfree to have a lot of courage and
I think you just proved you have a lot
of courage too and in the end isn't that
the true meaning of Pokemon yeah
you
you